I'm here at box parking wembley it's a
kind of place young people go to spend
the money their parents tell them they
should be saving let's go find out what
they think about boomers do you think
boomers show young people respect
that was pretty definitive they think
they were raised in the area in the era
where you know it was come out of them
sitting expected back
they don't really space I can already
see I've never really had any problem
with all the people if you treat people
nice hopefully they could treat the same
so that's how I feel I wouldn't want to
put a label on all people of that
generation but it feels like there's a
little lack of respect with the way that
Millennials are looked at do you think
[Music]
the environment hundred percent the
environment is one of the biggest issues
and it's not being taken seriously
enough so do you think boomers are
responsible for any of the problems that
we face as a society today probably
because they are stuck in their ways and
they're very black-and-white about
things so yeah which problems do you
think especially the politics and stuff
Leila the way that the one is going
especially with records you know getting
separating the different communities and
blocking maybe
coming to the country Russia I'm from
France and it feels sometimes like maybe
some people don't want us to be here
like they haven't done enough and like
cared as much and I feel like my
generation kind of has a lot more about
like climate change and like current
issues and that was the general feeling
towards boomers here not enough done to
stop climate change and a view that
they're responsible for brexit which
over 70% of 18 to 24 year-olds voted
against many also felt that boomers
didn't show young people much respect
but are these accusations fair I went to
the Royal Albert Hall where a Christmas
concert was taking place in the hope to
find some over 55 s who could tell me
what they really think of young people
do you think young people deserve
respect or should they earn it deserve
respect if they're behaved thank you I
think young people work harder than your
generation do no no easy
yes very very easy well things when we
can't find jobs when we worked we we
worked things were completely different
we didn't have computers therefore we
had to use what's in here speaking about
our grandchildren young people yes they
work hard very hard very hard very
worried about their futures the younger
ones are far more in tune and willing to
find out about things and are sold ease
or set in our ways yeah so know up to
the youngsters I say have you heard the
phrase okay boomer no I've got a Wonder
boom that's an echo no is the answer
I think the generations are different
times have changed
when I was a youngster growing up there
were lots of jobs lots of factories lots
of manufacturing that's all gone now we
work longer hours they seem to think
that sitting in a desk is very strenuous
and there's more prime peoples nowadays
there's always they don't want to wake
they want to sleep too much
and play on the phones and computers do
you think your generation worked harder
yeah
they worked at that we used to wake
either because I think this the
destruction is phones I know some really
really good young people I think given
the opportunity the the young people
today I would we do every bit as well as
we ever did and I think when it comes to
being tested you know when that comes to
be interested I they'll step up sort of
like I'm sure
[Music]